j'estime que monsieur dupont moretti
cette aube ira en pire oui et que
monsieur dupont moretti incarne
parfaitement le laxisme aujourd'hui qui
a imprégné une grande partie des juges à
une grande partie de l'état régalien
il nous a dit souvenez-vous il ya
quelques mois l'ensauvagement est un
fantasme l'insécurité est un fantasme
alors qu'on sortait d'un été la france
est extrêmement dur et je vais venir est
extrêmement dur qui a vu se dérouler 900
agressions par jour cet été une
agression gratuite toutes les 44
secondes dans notre pays c'est un
chiffre qui a été donnée au sein de au
sein du dans une annonce d'un article du
figaro d'ailleurs et il a dit il a eu
cette phrase il a dit la france n'est
pas un coupe gorge et bien les faits lui
donnent tort il doit démissionner mais
je pense qu'il n'est pas à sa place
qu'il doit démissionner je ne sais pas
s'il doit démissionner je pense que la
meilleure sanction ce celle des urnes
voilà et que lorsque max dupond-moretti
nous explique que la france n'est pas un
coupe gorge que l'ensauvagement est un
fantasme qu'il faut continuer avec les
remises les libérations anticipées qui
ont été ordonnées par madame belloubet
sous la période du coc vide et qui a
abouti à la libération de 13 mille
détenus dont des individus radicalisés
et des islamistes
eh bien oui n'est pas à sa place pour
donner justice lors du peuple français
est engagé ce tour de vis à l'égard de
la délinquance et la criminelle qui est
aujourd'hui nécessaire
[Musique]